Before we wrap up this course, I thought it might be useful to just go over a few other
features that you can maybe dig into and research through the documentation or directly through
the engine, just playing around and digging into the different tools.
So we can do landscape.
We have a landscape tool.
So if I just jump over to the engine from the select modes, you can select landscape
and edit vast landscapes.
And there's many powerful tools there to dig into.
There is paper 2D, which is a 2D engine of Unreal Engine, where you can create your own
2D games.
There are virtual production tools, which we briefly touched upon before, but there's a
lot going on in the virtual production space that are definitely worth digging into.
We've got end display.
We've got geometry editors, accessibility tools, take recorders, which are
take recorder is it can record a performance inside of Unreal Engine and create its own asset
type from that recorded performance for use for however you want to use those tools.
We've got automation tools and many, many more.
So it was a very kind of quick overview of everything Unreal Engine 5 has to offer.
There are plenty of avenues to go down, plenty of powerful tools for you to pick for your
project, depending on its needs and capabilities.
And hopefully from demonstrating here today, even though it can feel sometimes overwhelming
loading a new piece of software and there's so many buttons to click, you generally find
yourself getting into your own workflow, the things that you want to create, and it becomes
second nature.
So definitely worth just getting stuck in from the different touch points today.
Maybe there are a few different tools that really look interesting to you that you want
to explore further through the different courses that we have to offer or through the
documentation.
But I hope this was a useful overview of what Unreal Engine 5 has to offer.